thirty two storeys above the streets of
New York City a cat fell from a window
and lived after vets treated the cats
chipped tooth and collapsed lungs
the feline was sent home two days later
cats fall a lot and they've gotten
really good at it drop a cat upside down
for example and it will almost always
land on its feet
that's because cats are extremely
flexible they can twist their bodies
midair as they fall but landing feet
first isn't always the best strategy
like if you're falling from 32 storeys
up to figure out how cats manage that
perfect landing every time a series of
studies looked at over a hundred cats
falls from two to 32 stories up comes as
no surprise that cats who fell from the
second floor had fewer injuries than
cats who fell from the sixth floor but
here is the fascinating part above the
seventh story the extent of the injuries
largely stayed the same no matter how
high the cats fell so how is that
possible well it all comes down
acrobatics or lack thereof cats that
fell from two to seven stories up mostly
landed feet-first above that however
cats used a different technique instead
of positioning their legs straight down
as they fell they splayed out like a
parachute er and landed belly-first
instead but this method isn't 100%
foolproof chest trauma like a collapsed
lung or broken rib is more common with
this landing method but the risk of
breaking a leg is much less so how do
cats somehow subconsciously know how to
land it has to do with a physics
phenomenon called terminal velocity at
first the cat plummets faster and faster
under gravity until she's fallen the
equivalent of five stories at that point
she hits constant terminal velocity at
100 km/h she's now in freefall where air
friction counteracts her acceleration
under gravity at this point she's no
longer accelerating and more importantly
doesn't feel the pole from gravity so
here's what researchers think is
happening from two to seven stories up
cats don't have enough time to reach
terminal velocity and prep for landing
feet first but once they hit terminal
velocity their instinct changes and they
parachute their limbs all that said
don't throw your cat out of a window
can't believe I have to say this not
only is it still very dangerous it's not
very polite
don't throw your cat out the window just
to see all that go down just watch this
video again just turn just hit little
replay button